in this video i'm going to introduce you
to a new type of mathematical notation
that will seem fancy at first but
hopefully you'll appreciate is pretty
useful and also pretty straightforward
so let's just start with some things
that we already know
so i could have just a ten
i could take two tens and multiply them
together so ten times ten which you know
is equal to a hundred i could take three
tens and multiply them together ten
times ten
times 10 is equal to
1000 and i could do this with any number
of tens but at some point if i'm doing
this with enough tens it gets pretty
hard to write so for example let's say i
were to let's say i were to do this with
ten tens so if i were to do ten
times ten times ten times ten that's
four that's five
that's six that's seven that's eight
that's 9 that is 10 tens let's see 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 9 10. this is going to be
equal to even the number that it's equal
to is going to be quite hard to write
it's going to be 1 followed by 10 zeros
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10. let me put the
commas there so it's a little bit easier
to read this right over here is 10
billion and it's already getting kind of
hard to write and imagine if we had 30
tens that we were multiplying together
so mathematicians have come up with a
notation and some ideas to be able to
write things like this a little bit more
elegantly
so the way they do this is through
something known as exponents
exponents
and so
10 times 10 we can rewrite as being
equal to if i have two tens and i'm
multiplying them together i could write
this as 10
to the
second power that's how someone would
say it they would say 10 to the second
power that looks fancy but all that
means is let's take two tens and
multiply them together and we're going
to get 100
just so you're familiar with some of the
parts of this the 2 would be called the
exponent and the 10 would be the base so
10 to the second power is 10 times 10 is
equal to 100. so how would you write 10
times 10 times 10 or a thousand how
would you write that using exponents
pause this video and see if you can
figure that out
well as exactly as you might have
imagined we're taking a certain number
of tens and we see we're taking three
tens and we're multiplying them together
so this would be 10 to the third power
10 is the base 3 is the exponent we
would read this as 10 to the third power
if you ever saw 10 to the third power
that means hey let me multiply 10 times
10 times 10 that's the same thing as a
thousand so this is really another way
of writing a thousand
and what about this number here 10
billion what's a way that we could write
it using exponents pause the video and
figure that out
well as you might have imagined we're
taking 10 tens and multiplying them
together this is 10
to the
10th power
and we can go the other way around if
someone were to walk up to you on the
street and say what is 10
to the
5th power what is that what number that
you're probably familiar with would this
be
well this would mean that we're going to
take five tens and multiply them
together so 10 times 10
times 10 times 10 times 10.
and so 10 times 10 is 100 hundred times
ten is a thousand a thousand times ten
is ten thousand ten thousand times ten
is equal to one hundred
thousand
so there you have it you have the basics
of exponents when we're dealing with 10.
and i know you were thinking can i put
another number here instead of 10 and
the simple answer is you can but we're
not going to cover that just yet in this
video